hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown President Trump
is butting heads with Twitter after the
tech company added fact check links to
his tweets for the first time Fox News
Sunday host chris wallace joins host
lisa brady to weigh in on the debate
over alleged social media censorship and
what implications it could have on the
2020 presidential race while the nation
remains under phased social distancing
orders to prevent the spread of Kovan 19
some religious leaders are making a
First Amendment case to reopen places of
worship Charles Clarke the 3rd co-pastor
of solid rock Baptist Church and joins
host Dave Anthony to discuss his lawsuit
with New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy
plus commentary by former deputy
national security adviser katie
mcfarland the fox news rundown is a
Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com Rivera hi I'm Emily Campania
and I'm Eric Sean this is a Fox News
rundown
[Music]
Friday May 29th 2020 Alisa Brady
fact-checking the president Twitter
makes a move and he fires back
but is this a slippery slope for social
media I'd be perfectly happy if
everything politician said is fact
checked and everything I say is back
jack that's fine
but you can't do it if you just can't
and and you know there's always gonna be
some bias I'm Dave Anthony it's
happening across America religious
leaders defying governor's opening up
their churches even going to courts we
don't want this we didn't look for a
fight and what we want to do is be put
in the category of essential it is
essential to our people for them to have
their right we have people discouraged
we have people depressed we have people
that just want to show their love for
God by attending church and i'm katie
mcfarland i've got the final word on the
fox news rundown
[Music]
President Trump is taking aim at big
tech with his pen instead of his phone
my executive order calls for new
regulations under Section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act to make it
that social media companies that engage
in censoring or any political conduct
will not be able to keep the Alaia
bility shield the Act was passed by
Congress in 1996 and the president says
there may be bipartisan support for
changes he's also asking his
administration to make sure no taxpayer
dollars go to social media companies
that repress free speech the president
and others have long argued there's an
anti conservative bias online and in the
media but the tipping point was
Twitter's decision to add a fact check
label to presidential tweets about
mail-in voting fraud a first even after
years of controversial tweets Facebook
CEO Mark Zuckerberg tells Fox's Dana
Perino he still opposes fact-checking
political speech and that his platform
is more about freedom of expression I
just believed strongly that Facebook
shouldn't be the arbiter of truth of
everything that people say online that
drew skepticism from House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi who accuses Zuckerberg of
pandering to the White House hoping to
avoid regulation the danger in that is
once you go down that slope unless
you're gonna be you're gonna fact-check
everything everybody says and lord knows
are there things the president says that
aren't true yes are there things that
Joe Biden says and Democrats say that
aren't true yes
Chris Wallace is the host of Fox News
Sunday so if you're gonna fact-check the
president are you gonna fact-check Joe
Biden if you're gonna fact-check
you know some Republican congressman are
you gonna fact-check a Democratic
congressman and so it becomes a very
dangerous thing because if you don't if
you're not even habit you don't
fact-check everybody then people are
gonna see bias well it did you know
fact-checking one side not the other I
remember when I got to moderate a
presidential debate in 2016 between
Trump and Clinton Howie Kurtz asked me
are you going to truth squad are you
gonna fact-check what both of the people
said and I said
you know I'm not and there was a big
blowup
you know why aren't you gonna to do that
and the reason I gave is kind of the
reasoning I'm giving here if you were
gonna fact-check one thing that Canada
Trump said I then aren't you obligated
to fact-check one thing that Hillary
Clinton said and then you're down a
slippery slope and instead of it being a
debate between the two candidates and
let people figure it out for themselves
now you're a third party in the ring I
kind of think Twitter they have gotten
into the middle of it and may regret it
and the Twitter CEO is saying basically
look we're not trying to be the arbiter
of truth we're just trying to you know
point people in the right direction for
more information but the White House is
saying the president's being singled out
and that for instance Twitter was not
fact-checking
Chinese propaganda blaming the US
military for coronavirus as an example
until the White House pointed it out
this also goes along to with claims from
the president and others for a long time
now that conservative voices in general
are singled out and silenced on social
media I mean just feed into that
well it certainly feeds into it I I
don't know enough to know the facts as
to whether or not it's true but you know
it certainly does feed into the idea
that they have a thumb on the scale you
know Twitter has got special protections
that publishers whenever the New York
Times doesn't have that the Fox News
doesn't have and they say that they're a
platform they're not a publisher so
therefore they say they're not
responsible and under the law section
230 I just found out about it under that
some 1996 law they can't be held
responsible if somebody says something
libelous on their website they're
basically saying we're just carrying
this we're not saying who's right or
who's wrong we're not standing behind it
look I would love everything to be fact
Chuck I'm I'm in the truth business and
I'd be perfectly happy if everything
politician said is fact check and
everything I say is fact check that's
fine but you can't do it you just can't
and and you know there's always going to
be some bias and what you decide is so
false it needs to be fact check
and that just lends itself to the
argument that there's political bias
political favoritism in what you call
out and what you don't this issue of
mail and voting which is what prompted
the fact check could it be a dangerous
one for the president if people don't
feel safe going to the polls are they
going to resent him or anyone else that
appears to stand in the way of a safer
option well you know all I know on this
and and and this was as you say quite
rightly what got us into the the Twitter
controversy is you know I've done a
certain amount of research on it and it
doesn't seem to be an indication of
widespread or really almost any fraud
associated with mail-in voting it goes
on in Republican states it goes on in
democratic states the Utah couldn't be
more conservative state has all-male in
voting in its elections and it doesn't
seem to favor one party over another in
fact one of the groups did you know
beyond the question of trying to do this
in the middle of a pandemic although we
hope that we'll be better by November is
that one of the groups that that is uses
mail-in voting for health reasons
physical disability reasons the most is
seniors people over 65 and they tend to
vote Republicans so to the degree that
you make it harder to mail and vote the
Republicans may be hurting their one of
their own constituencies not to mention
as you say yes you know we were to have
a second wave or there's a sufficient
concern still about the coronavirus in
october/november early voting in the
actual election day and people feel with
gee i had to vote because the president
stopped it you know there might be some
backlash that's one other fact here here
you have Kaylee McEnaney speaking out
defending the president attacking mail
and voting and somebody found out she's
a resident of Florida that she has voted
nailin voted something like 10 or 12
times in the last decade so you know
again it raises the question well if
it's okay for her why isn't okay for
everybody else alright I think she's
echoing the president's argument that
yes absentee voting is fine when needed
but that they're concerned a mass
mailing of ballots out to everyone
increases the risk of fraud somehow Joe
Biden in the meantime finally got out of
his basement as both he and the
president marched Memorial Day even that
ended up having political overtones
though because Biden wore masks and the
president did not yeah I had actually
said I think on the this this rundown
that I thought that the guide needed to
get out of the basement last week you
know there just didn't seem to be any
excuse people are getting out obviously
under very controlled conditions and you
know the the the Biden needed to get out
he couldn't be running you can't run for
president be a prisoner for two and a
half months in your basement now I have
kind of mixed feelings about the
controversy over what happened on
Memorial Day
on the one hand I don't understand why
Biden at some point when it was just him
and and and Jill Biden his wife and they
obviously have been together for two and
a half months in the basement
why couldn't you know as he was taking
the the wreath to the memorial in
Delaware why couldn't have taken off his
mask it struck me is is looking a little
silly having said that I understand when
you're around people and I hate that
masks have now become a political issue
and you know now whether you wear a mask
or don't says something about whether
you're a liberal or a conservative
Republican or a Democrat tough or weak
you know all of the science indicates if
you're close to people you should wear a
mask if you're within six feet you
should wear a mask not to protect
yourself but to protect other people and
the idea that that's going to become
part of the political debate I think is
really dangerous particularly at a time
when we're trying to reopen the country
we ought to be doing it as safely as
possible and you know I was horrified as
I think anybody has to be when I saw all
of those people partying in lake of the
ozarks or at some of the beaches over
more
Day weekend you know that's the kind of
thing that's going to cause a second
spike so if you believe in reopening and
you believe in trying to kill the virus
and then you know tamp it down then wear
a mask and socially distance everybody
says something both Biden and the
president have also come out fairly
quickly and condemned the death of
George Floyd in Minneapolis the own arms
black forgery suspect who died in police
custody politicians they'll always have
to be careful what they say and how they
say it right especially when the nation
is already hurting so much right now 40
million out of work because of the
pandemic now over a hundred thousand
dead it's just a difficult time all
around in a very tense time yes but when
when people are out raised as I think
they should be by seeing a man who was
was look you know I wouldn't be a
policeman you know there was there there
used to be an ad and it showed an empty
alley a dark alley and it said you
wouldn't go down that alley for all the
money in the world
a policeman go down for a lot less and
it's true you know policemen are put in
really tough situations which is why for
instance in Ferguson with a very big guy
Michael Brown who was allegedly charging
and a police officer I'm not going to
sit there in second-guessed what's an
appropriate use of force but when you
see the video and you see this man and
you know he was handcuffed and he was
handcuffed behind his back and for
minute after minute I think four to five
minutes
he's begging please I can't breathe
please let me up and the guy has his
knee and it seems his full weight
pressed on his neck that was you know I
used me that's outrageous and and I
think that politicians without saying
whether maybe whether they need to go to
jail or what the punishment should be
need to say to a community you know
we've had a few and we're going to talk
about it on Fox News Sunday we've had a
few racial incidents in the last few
weeks whether it was the Armory case of
the guy out for a jog in Georgia who
gets shot whether it was that awful case
it didn't thankfully didn't end up worse
with the woman with the
dog and and in central park calling the
police and saying she was being attacked
by an african-american when she wasn't
now this case which is you know maybe
the worst of all people leaders need to
speak out about that and and you know
not to fan the flames and Mort knows we
don't want riots but to say we
understand and we're going to try to fix
this and and you know this is
unacceptable behavior in this country in
the year 2020 Chris Wallace host of Fox
News Sunday looking forward to it and
thanks for being with us thank you Lisa
[Music]
this is katie mcfarland with your fox
news commentary coming up it's Church
vs. states a battle that started with
the coronavirus shutdowns in March
heating up as we end May in America we
need more prayer not less President
Trump has order they all be allowed to
open the people are demanding to go to
church and synagogue go to their mosque
many millions of Americans embrace
worship as an essential part of life but
critics question his authority over
governors on this and he replied the
other day if they want to play games
that's okay
but we will win and we have many
different ways where I can override them
some churches are defying orders so I'm
tearing up this cease and desist order
right here and I'm telling you right now
we're gonna do it God's Way Stacy Schiff
would have been told he can't have more
than ten people in his Calvary Baptist
Church in Baltimore County Maryland he
told Fox we do not defend and take up
for and insist on our god-given in a
little rights and our constitutional
freedoms then nobody else will a similar
story is playing out in New Jersey
Democratic governor Phil Murphy is still
not allowing public gatherings of 10 or
more people citing safety concerns his
state has the second most corona cases
in the US but some churches are opening
and holding services anyway well so much
about church is the importance of
gathering together as a church family
Charles Clark the third is co-pastor of
solid rock Baptist Church in Berlin New
Jersey and he's ready to take the
governor to court and so for us as
preachers learning how to primarily
preach to a camera and have services in
front of a camera it was okay it's been
good I'm glad we live in this age where
there's a technology but church family
gathering it is just so very important
because of the human aspect and and the
isolation that's going on with the
people has been very difficult for them
and difficult for us people want to meet
people want to assemble and so we
learned how to deal with it but it's
definitely not the same as having Church
in the building
and I know the lot of the anger that's
been brewing over this issue is that you
as a church are essentially deemed
non-essential and that has bothered a
lot of people I'm sure that bothers you
yeah we can't have churches
discriminated against and and the heart
of the matter is this churches have
religious liberty rights under the First
Amendment we are listed first in line
and our governor governor Murphy has
taken us out of the line there's been
almost no communication to the church
and they've said the big-box stores and
I'm not gainst those we go to them as we
need to but to say that those are
essential the liquor store is essential
but the church is supposed to stay
shuttered there is no part of that that
is constitutional and so we are an
organization as a local church that's
all about loving people taking care of
people if it's not too dangerous to go
into Walmart then is not too dangerous
to go into the church Church can do
things right
I'm not flattering ourselves we can do
it better than the box stores and and
and I'm not against them having freedom
but you cannot say religious liberty
just gets pushed aside Attorney General
bar has made clear that the Constitution
doesn't go out the window during the
time of a pandemic there have been legal
challenges across America and two cases
have reached the Supreme Court as
emergency appeals that might be
considered one out of Illinois the other
out of California religion cannot be
singled out and we are still being
singled out with restrictions no one
else faces bishop Arthur Hodges from the
South Bay United Pentecostal Church the
state only lets him open the 25 percent
capacity capped at no more than 100
worshipers and he told fox's martha
maccallum factories continue to operate
with no restrictions on how many people
in the factories hundreds of people in
the factories space just a few feet
apart
airplanes continue to fly with zero
state or federal regulation and pastor
Clark feels the same way which is why he
went ahead and held services for the
first time last Sunday yes sir we did it
was wonderful
and how many people showed up okay so we
made a decision that was social
distancing in our auditorium which holds
roughly a thousand people that we would
put around 250 in the building and so we
did not press any of our members you
have to come absolutely not we're
continuing our online and we've told our
seniors especially listen hey there's no
pressure on you to come here
I didn't forbid people that are seniors
to come I mean how do you say that to an
American citizen you're not allowed to a
church I can't deny them of that this
Sunday we're actually going to start a
special seniors only service for those
who want to come to that early morning
on Sunday but but basically our people
did reservations to come and we socially
distance them in our auditorium there
are spacers on each Pew we're going
every other Pew our parking is social
distance meaning we're going every other
spot people come in they wear a mask
anybody coming in the building has to
wear a mask they have their temperature
taken at the door touchless temperature
anybody 100 point four or more would not
be allowed in the building all the doors
are open so it's a touchless entry our
song books have been taken out of the
pews we do not have a choir we have HEPA
air filters air scrubbing turning over
the area in the air in our auditorium
our bathrooms are closed except for near
emergencies and and it's one stall
meaning one family unit or person goes
in at a time and when they come out we
then sanitize the bathroom after those
either individuals and families have
gone into the bathrooms I really don't
know what else we could do besides put
on hazmat suits to be safer in our
church now the governor yes still isn't
allowing churches to open up yet in New
Jersey did you have anybody stop by did
you have any police presence did you
have any issues with you defying orders
last Sunday and what about this coming
Sunday so we knew he is not looking at
giving church favor and putting us in
the category of essential so we've been
pressed to just set our date which was
the 24th last Sunday
and say listen we're gonna open our
doors so we received our citation from
our town here and it's literally where
it says the offense is opening the
church opening solid rock for a group of
ten or more people my dad who's 74 years
old
senior pastor I think I think this is
just tragic received a citation the
state of New Jersey vs. him and he's put
over 40 years in ministering for the
gospel of the Lord Jesus Christ here in
our state so this will trigger the start
of our lawsuit against governor Murphy
we don't want this we didn't look for a
fight and what we want to do is be put
in the category of essential it is
essential to our people for them to have
their right we have people discouraged
we have people depressed we have people
that just want to show their love for
God by attending church and that's the
right so the police are very conflicted
I'll be very direct with you once we've
talked and talked to because it's their
job but many side with us and we're not
trying to put pressure on them like join
our cause I don't want policemen to lose
their job based on a governor's
overreach we believe we're going to win
in court so we've had a good
relationship with our local police here
and the county police work together to
provide safety for our church family on
Sunday we didn't know whether it be
protesters or even supporters what could
happen there's been concerns because of
other situations in the country so the
law enforcement here in south jersey
with us has been wonderful it's the
governor's office it's you know giving
us grief have you filed the lawsuit yet
we are beginning that process this week
we had to wait for our citation we knew
we would get it and so he's well aware
that we're here nobody's called me from
the governor's office they know at this
point since they're coming on so strong
he gives no indication other than you
know while the numbers don't say so
here's reality both now and moving
forward the church has its First
Amendment rights we cannot wait for the
governor to give thumbs up thumbs down
bluntly at his whims or not he's not
said what goes into factoring essential
or not so how does he just disregard the
church and say liquor stores marijuana
dispensaries they're open the whole time
no matter what the numbers were but
god-fearing people in the United States
of New Jersey in the United States of
America and New Jersey Constitution
having constitutional rights have been
thrown out the door did the citation
come with a fine
it doesn't say and and honestly the
governor has been asked about this the
reason why he can't speak definitively
in my opinion as to what's gonna happen
to us is because it's an executive order
this is not normal law yes he has Tenth
Amendment and yes there's an extended
time where because of the pandemic he
can make choices but these are not just
supposed to go on forever and so the
whole fine system or you know he keeps
you know repercussions is his response
to what's gonna happen but it's it's
gonna get tricky based on how things go
in court and then our response to how
things go in court but she'll be open
for services again someday right we have
our Sunday services and we will be
having continuing our services it is our
First Amendment right is our New Jersey
right and is our Bible mandate we are a
Christian Church and because people have
decided to follow the teachings of Jesus
Christ part of that is that we assemble
as a church family and and they want to
come no one is making anyone come to our
church there's no guarantee of safety
any time any of us leave our front door
and sometimes you wonder if you know
meaning but but the numbers people have
sense people can see we are going above
CDC measures here at solid rock Baptist
Church and yet the governor still does
not look at what we're doing and
acknowledge it he talks about sedentary
and the idea of sitting people working
in the box stores they're in those
places all day and and the and meaning
you know there's not just the in and out
the doors what about the workers what
about the employees and how can he look
at what we're doing and find fault with
it I don't know but I know this
he says really no timeframe no timetable
we're not willing to do that because
whatever the virus does in the future
what if he locks down again on us and
just says okay no chirps that would be a
loss of religious liberty I'm not saying
that the initial intent of flattening
the curve was to take away religious
liberty but losing religious liberty
cannot become a byproduct of the
coronavirus situation what happens if
some of your parishioners get sick and
and and somebody's spread it in church
that's a really difficult question
number one we're praying that it won't
happen number two we're trying to do
everything we can to not let it happen
but it is a reality that it could okay
so how we would deal with that in the
kind of context of medically you know
obviously I'll go on record and say this
we will deal with that if it ever does
come as safely as we can and and and but
but I guess what I'm saying is this when
the founding fathers put the Bill of
Rights together and and throughout
American history there's been all types
of pandemics there's been all types of
problems including health issues if you
think over the course of our American
history but the church has continued the
church has continued and I will be on
record and say we're not closing the
doors to can we may have to go through
some difficult times but but you know
this idea that just automatically
churches the only place that you have to
be worried about getting the coronavirus
I don't agree with that well we wish you
well and thank you so much for joining
us Charles Clark the third co-pastor
solid rock Baptist Church in Berlin New
Jersey thank you thank you Dave
[Music]
it's the Perino and steyr Walt I'll tell
you what podcast Dana Perino of the five
and Fox News political editor Chris
Stein watch Isaac the ins and outs of
national politics subscribe and listen
now by going to fox news podcasts
dot-com
Rayden review the fox news rundown on
Apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with Tonya J
powers Kovan 19 has removed the expected
the normal the things we once thought of
as ordinary gatherings like friendly
get-togethers birthday parties and
graduations have taken on a whole new
look with social distancing guidelines
and mask-wearing but some people have
resorted to creative ways to put a safe
spin on events even street parties a
good example of that happened in las
vegas where a parking lot was
transformed into a drive-by carnival
think halloween trunk or treating but
without the costumes and more social
distancing more than 50 cars drove
through the event which means kids could
participate in dunk tanks and other
carnival games from the safety of their
cars they got gift bags balloons and
cotton candy - it was hosted by the
Friendship Circle a nonprofit that helps
put on programming for those with
special needs rabbi levi harley is the
director wanna give special needs
community a chance to get out of the
house everyone's having a hard time but
it could be event organizers made sure
to wear gloves and masks during the
carnival tania joy powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
katie mcfarland what's on your mind a
picture starting to emerge about the
abuse of power against the incoming
trump administration orchestrated by a
cabal about going in bomb administration
officials House Democrats the
intelligence community and their allies
in the media turns out the entire Russia
investigation was a sham and Obama
administration officials knew it from
the get-go senior intelligence officials
testified before closed-door
congressional hearings that there was no
collusion between the Trump campaign and
the Russians yet Director of National
Intelligence James clapper CIA director
John Brennan FBI director James Comey
FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe and
House Intelligence Committee Chairman
Adam Schiff what I'm cable news shows
day after day implying were saying
outright to the American people that
they had proof of collusion and that
Donald Trump would never have been
elected without Russian interference
well even now with a steady accumulation
of evidence and more to follow don't
expect any of these people to come clean
or to admit their mistakes instead
they're doubling down and coming up with
new excuses to justify their actions one
you're likely to hear more of in the
days ahead comes from that faithful few
days in late December 2016 when
President Obama imposed sanctions on the
Russians for election interference the
administration expected the Russians to
retaliate on the eve of Trump's
inauguration leaving the new president a
US Russia crisis to greet his arrival at
the White House when the Russians didn't
retaliate Obama directed the
intelligence community to find out why
with the presumption that Trump must
have cut a deal with Putin during the
final days of the transition at that
time the president-elect was at
mar-a-lago I was there also in my role
as a senior national security adviser
this is what the FBI and Muller
prosecutors grilled me about for more
than 30 hours and several interrogation
sessions center the summer fall and
winter of 2017 in 18 they were convinced
there was a smoking gun somewhere and
that I was the middleman they presumed
that president-elect ronk directed me to
tell Flynn to make promises to the
Russians in exchange
for not retaliating I insisted over and
over again that it wasn't the case the
Trump gave me no such order yet they
persisted what they never figured out or
never wanted to figure out was that
Putin probably played us all along Putin
didn't retaliate against Obama sanctions
because it wasn't in his best interest
to do so
he had far more to lose and perpetuating
the bad relationship he had with the
Obama administration into the new trump
administration either the senior
officials of the Obama administration
including Obama himself were incompetent
in analyzing Putin or deliberately use
it as their excuse for investigating and
wiretapping Flynn and others the Russia
hoax was all designed to prevent
President Trump from doing what the
American people elected him to do drain
the swamp why did the cabal want to stop
Trump because they are the swamp the
American people have paid a very high
price for the Russia hoax even if the
investigation of the investigators
uncovers the rot in the intelligence
community the ramifications of their
actions will live on by setting
Americans at each other's throats for
three years our adversaries especially
the Chinese were able to exploit our
divisions to their advantage that is the
real crime against the American people
the Cabal distracted us from the growing
strategic threat so they could play
nasty games against their political
opponents I'm Katie McFarland and I was
president Trump's first deputy national
security adviser I'm the author of the
best-selling book revolution Trump
Washington and We the People
you've been listening to the Bucks news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com love Fox News
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the FoxNews rundown playlist for
the latest episodes